foreign
so uh before we go to
my new friend Sammy so I recently had a
show and on the show I
was talking to somebody
um
about with a newborn with a kid
and you know I was someone who was about
to have a kid or was considering having
a kid was that what it was
yeah it was the guy that
um was nervous about having a kid there
you go okay okay and I made the
statement
um you will never truly know the depths
of your ability to love until you hold
your first child and
um usually
Instagram like social media is one of
two things it's like yeah bro you go
girl or it's
you're the worst person ever and I would
like to set you on fire
um and then occasionally I get really
thoughtful
um what I would say thoughtful good
engagement like pushback like I disagree
with that occasionally my friends like
Dr Norton will call me and be like hey
you botched that one big time here's the
reality
um but I sometimes will get some
thoughtful pushback and this particular
time
um with someone I've never met never
talked to I'm about to hear but it was
Sammy from uh Indiana and she reached
out and was super kind and um so Sammy
I'm gonna bring you in here Sam you
there yeah I'm here dude number one
thank you so much for even agreeing to
be on the show and to talk this through
um
I want to tell you out of the gate I'm
so grateful that you had the courage to
write in and say I think I disagree with
what you're saying and I I that meant
the world to me how you did it why you
did it and you gave some great
rationales like you I could tell that
you were
uh not just throwing grenades and so on
behalf of humanity who's all stuck in
this instagrammy world thank you for
being a good idea for being a good human
how are you yeah no problem I'm good how
are you doing good good good
um okay so I reached out back to you and
said hey would you I would love to talk
about this on the show because I I know
this particular
conversation is being had all over the
place and it's a group it's a part of a
broader conversation I've been
struggling with um as I'm trying to
write write a new book and try to dig
into some of the scholarship around this
stuff so
for everybody listening walk us back
through I make the statement on the show
you'll never truly know the depth of
your ability to love the depths of love
until you hold your first kid
and you heard that and you're in our
gang and tell me how that hits you what
you felt what you thought walk me
through that
and yeah don't spare my feelings by the
way let it rip okay
okay yeah so I've been listening to
every episode you've come out with and
it's just been a great place for me to
connect a different um topics in my life
that I've been going through and so I
really respect you and what all you have
to say and I really take everything that
you say to heart so when you said that
it it kind of broke my heart a little
bit
um just because I hear a lot of that
talk in the world saying like you'll
never know love until you have a kid and
I think it just puts a lot of other
people who don't have kids into this
weird situation where we're less than uh
so tell me
so my wife and I struggled with
infertility for years years and years
um and so I I get that impulse tell me
where
um tell me why it makes you feel less
than
um
because it feels like people think
you're only important if you have kids
and you won't contribute anything else
into the world unless you have kids
where does that story come from
um
I think I'm mostly hear it from parents
okay
um
yeah so a little backstory
me my husband have been married for
almost seven years okay and we always
like nonchalantly would say that we
would have kids
um but that always just got pushed back
and back and back and then my sister I
have an identical twin sister
um she had her first kid in 2020 and so
that's when everyone started bombarding
me but oh one of you guys gonna have
kids and that's kind of when we started
you know really thinking like is this
something we actually want to do because
it's a huge major decision that I think
a lot of people just don't take the time
to think about a lot so that's just what
we've been thinking about for the past
couple years and trying to make that
decision
so how has that is as y'all land on the
decision of are we going to do this are
we going to not
how is that how are you feeling pulled
in a less than position
um just the way that like some parents
and some other people talk to
people who don't have kids it's like oh
well you think you're tired well try
being up with a newborn and like always
trying to one-up people who don't have
kids or think that oh you're not going
through any anything hard in your life
uh or you don't yeah I'll give you
something to cry about right yeah yeah
okay okay
so
a couple of thoughts here I I I
absolutely remember that
and I remember I remember walking past a
room in our house and we had made the
decision to have kids we couldn't right
so
um but we also didn't want to announce
that to the world I remember having a
hard hard conversation with a family
member and who said hey we've made some
decisions because y'all clearly don't
want kids and it was like a knife to the
soul dude you know what I mean because I
was like well hold on like just because
you know I mean you made all these
suppositions about me and my my wife and
our family and
um so yeah that's brutal
um and I I want you to hear me say like
loud and clear
there there is no less than
right it's just simply different and but
I will say this
my wife and I were talking and she said
something once when she was first
pregnant with Hank and it stuck with me
and then I circled back to it when she
was uh it went another several years and
had a couple of wild surgeries and
wildness
um one life-saving surgery and then we
ended up with Josephine
she said I feel sorry for you this is
her talking to me I said why and she
said you will never know how close I am
to our son
I was like yes you have his dad
and she goes no dude he's been in my
body for nine months you'll never know
you'll never know what how close I am
breastfeeding kid in the middle of the
night just us two you're snoozing like
an old man like and I had to
there was a moment of yeah you're
exactly right I'm never gonna know that
and it doesn't mean that I was less than
or that I was dysfunctional or broken
but it was all it was just it was just
it just was a was right and so what I'm
wrestling with and you can you can I'm
hoping you can teach me I'm wrestling
with how do I
absorb truth in my life dude I had a dog
her name was Molly she was a basset
hound she was my hound dog she slept on
my pillow with me
um the joke in my house was she was in
my bed long before my wife was like that
dog was my ride or die I brought her to
meetings I brought that dog everywhere
and
um like I loved that dog I loved that
dog
I loved my friends dearly
and then I held my first kid and so I
don't feel like I'm in a place where I
can honestly say I understood what that
meant until
and at the same time how do I
communicate that without inferring that
it's somehow better than
it's just an is right like some pools
are three feet deep some pools are 20
feet deep
um depending on what you want to do with
your life pools are going to be
different but I can't deny that pool's
20 feet deep
so how how do I is it something that you
have to own that I'm not gonna let
people make me feel less than is it
something that I need to own when I'm
communicating to something we need to do
it together how do we how do we have
that conversation
I think it's it's both parties
um the one side who is the child free
couple you know like being firm in their
stance and saying like this is what we
want
um like we won't feel bad for it but
then I think on the other side it's for
people to accept that and to not you
know feel bad for them or think they're
less than or
um
like when you said you won't know you
won't truly know love until you hold
your kid there are other ways to love
people
um
like I understand it's a different love
so I think just for people who have kids
not totally summarizing something and
equating that to kids ah so maybe a
better way to say it was you won't ever
know the depth of
Your Capacity to love until you hold
your first kid but that doesn't mean
you're not going to love deeply and
wildly and recklessly and like so
there's different yeah so I I can see
where I said that incorrectly because I
made a blanket statement about love
you'll never know love until you've done
this that's not true
yeah right
huh okay that makes sense so on behalf
of myself
uh I apologize for saying it that way
because I made a blanket statement about
the nature of love that just simply was
inaccurate
um and I think I should have said it
differently and said
um and you guys listening I'm I'm
processing this in real time I should
have said
there's a depth and a capacity to love
that you won't understand until you
you're responsible for
um or to you hold somebody but that
doesn't mean you're not ever gonna love
right you're gonna have your spouse you
have your friends you're gonna have your
pets you're gonna have whatever you're
gonna love all sorts of people
um yeah that makes sense I love that
okay so how do you on your side
um
how do you create a world where other
people don't get a vote or very select
few people get a vote
[Laughter]
live that seems like an exhausting way
to live
no I think it was more exhausting
letting other people
have
the freedom to my
like the past couple years because I've
gone through a lot of hard things in my
life
um I've learned to
um what emotions do I allow to each
person
and so and that the whole kids subject
is one of them because I know that some
people will say dumb stuff because they
just don't know yeah you know they don't
know the situation I'm in so I let that
slide but then you know once someone
does know my stance then you keep
you know saying the same stuff then I
think that's where the education comes
in
could I recommend instead of looking to
form calluses
looking to because here's what I think
when I think um I'm forming calluses the
image in my head is of a tightening fist
I'm becoming hard and strong to this
instead of opening my hands even wider
and letting that kind of stuff pass
through me like air like a spirit right
um I I'm gonna make my way through life
not trying to be calloused as much as
I'm gonna let that pass through me like
wind like that's not even a thing you
can say whatever you want and that's not
gonna affect my mood or my body's not
gonna feel like it has to respond in
some sort of does that make sense
one of those feels like a lot of work
and the other feels like a infinitely
less anxious way to live
yeah I don't think I'm necessarily like
have like grew up as a kid who it was
very emotional and was you know let my
parents really control those emotions
and so as an adult I've had to learn
what do I allow people into well good
for you and how do I respond to things
awesome awesome awesome
um did you have you ever did you read
that uh own your past change of future
that Booker wrote
um I started to and then my husband took
it and he started reading it and gave me
some Cliff Notes good job so I want you
to hang on the line I want you to read
it there's a there's a story in that
book um about my friend Lisa who was in
my one of my counseling cohorts and
um I'll I'll uh I'll end this call this
way
um we were sitting in a circle and I've
told the story on the show before we
were sitting in a circle as as
counseling classes do and we were
talking about you know different
scenarios different case studies and um
one of my great mentors and friends and
Professor Dr uh Brett Hendricks he laid
out
um a case study
and the case study was what happens if
you've been working with a client for
like six months and the client walks in
and looks at you and says hey you suck
at this
you've taken my money for six months I
paid you thousands of dollars I did your
little exercise with my S with my
romantic partner and she left me I did
your little how to ask for a raise
exercise and my boss and not only didn't
give me the raise but gave me like a
like a reprimand you're not good at what
you and I was new to it right I was just
seeing clients in my practical and I
remember
saying out loud that would kill me that
would decimate me and
um Lisa who was one of the most wise
she's just awesome she's brilliant she's
been a therapist for years and years and
years she looked at me and said John
they don't get that and I rolled my eyes
and I was like oh gosh is that one like
dumb counselor speak and she said magic
words you get to choose who hurts your
feelings
and I was like no that's not right and
she goes yeah other people can take away
your livelihood and or actually on the
way home I was thinking about this other
people could take away your livelihood
they can take away they can they can
um wreck your car they can take your job
away they can take your life away
but I get to choose who I give access to
my heart in order to hurt me and I asked
her I was like oh so how many people do
you give access to your heart you know I
was trying to rolling my eyes and she
said like five four five or six
something like that a very small number
and so on my on my bike ride home uh
I'll never forget this it was a hot west
Texas afternoon the wind was blowing it
was hot and I was riding my bike and I
was frustrated and I was trying to think
who would I allow in this little magical
box
and I realized I was allowing everybody
I was allowing all my students all my
students parents all these
administrators all these people at other
universities I didn't know who were
colleagues
um I was letting internet people I was
like all kinds so I just started
whittling it down I took my parents out
and who I love I love my parents
but I took them out of the box I took my
in-laws out I took all these different
people and I got down to four or five or
six people and I remember
um calling a couple of them and said hey
I just want you to know I've given you
access
to my innermost being use it wisely
please
because if you tell me like hey you're
being an idiot you're being foolish or
you've made a terrible mistake I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna respond in kind
because I trust you and I'll tell you
this it was the single most freeing
exercise I've done in years
um I felt like uh like I was free if my
wife tells me something if my buddy Todd
like a very select group of people if
they tell me something I'm in right
other than that people just don't get a
vote and I'll tell you it's like like I
was describing it's like opening your
hand up to the world and letting it just
be so
um I want to thank you for being so
thoughtful and kind in your response and
for calling me out and saying hey I
experience love
and all over the place and I don't have
kids and so what you said isn't accurate
doesn't hold true and the way I said
that I still holding my my belief that
the capacity for love deepens when you
hold your kid but it's just simply
dishonest to say you will never know
love right that's just not true and so I
want to thank you for calling me out in
such a uh dignified and respectable way
and I really appreciate you Sammy
yeah thanks for um
I know some people don't but thanks for
being open to it of course man and um
hang on the line here and we're gonna
get you a copy of the book and um that
way your husband won't steal your crap
anymore he'd get his he can get his own
how kind will that be awesome Sammy
you're the best